I know you've talked about the heroes to
journey before you work with Chris low
glare on that now what are some of the
other things you've done with character
arc well when I talked about the heroes
two journeys that you're referring to a
seminar Chris Vogler and I gave some
years ago and we created a video of it
that is now on streaming video and so on
that's available to people and the
reason I gave at that title is because
in a story that goes in in any kind of
depth with the character the hero is
actually going to take two journeys so
to speak one is the one I just described
it's a journey of accomplishment it's
it's a journey where the hero and I
should define by hero I simply mean the
protagonist I'm talking about a man
woman boy girl Android anthropomorphic
animal if we're talking about Zootopia
let's say but whoever that main
character is that my definition is the
hero a hero is not someone by the way is
who is heroic it's someone who has the
potential to become heroic and the
movies going to be about do they or
don't they fulfill that potential but at
the start it's an everyday person but
they have this visible finish line
that's the journey of accomplishment are
they going to stop the alien invasion
are they going to stop the serial killer
are they going to escape there's a movie
that is one of my favorite movies this
year from New Zealand called hunt for
the wilderness foster father who have to
go on the run because of a series of
circumstances that were rooting for them
to get away from the evil social worker
and the cops were coming after them and
so on it's funny and it's touching and
so on but it's in but their goal is to
get away from the bad people to escape
or it could be to win a competition but
whatever that goal is when you hear what
it is we can envision it it's visible so
that's why it's like I say the outer
motivation is the outer journey of
accomplishment but underneath that a
hero in many movies and many novels is
going to take another journey what I
call the inner journey for the hero
and whereas with the outer journey the
obstacles and the conflict come from the
outside world either forces of nature or
other characters on the inner journey
the conflict is going to come from
within the character so this is a
journey of transformation it's actually
a journey from living in fear to living
courageously now the way that works in
essence is if you're creating an inner
journey for your hero you need to ask
yourself first of all what was this
character's wound how was this character
hurt in the past in some way what was
this painful experience in the past that
they think they've dealt with they think
they've put it behind them but they
haven't really because it's still
affecting how they behave so let's take
one of my favorite examples of this is
Good Will Hunting
so in Good Will Hunting Will Hunting we
discover through the course of that
movie was beaten by his father on an
almost daily basis he took a belt to him
he was abused so that was so painful
that it has stayed with him and it's
affecting how he's now behaving because
when we are wounded like that when we
have that sort of deeply painful
experience we're going to formulate a
belief about what caused that about how
the world works about why that could
have happened
so we'll hunting's belief is I must have
deserved it
typical belief that comes up for kids
who are abused in childhood in real life
as well okay or if you take a movie like
gravity where her wound is her daughter
has died and now she's just sort of
floating out into space disconnected
from everything just not able to move
forward with her life because her belief
is all I have left is the memory of my
daughter
I just have to cling to that anything to
move forward in life is going to be too
painful and too scary and I can't risk
letting go of that memory at all
so she's just stuck in that place so
those beliefs that grow out of those
those those wounding experience
cies lead to specific fears so she's
afraid of living her life Will Hunting
is afraid of letting anybody see who he
truly is and then out of that fear that
grows out of the belief that comes from
this wound from the past in real life
and in stories we will all create what I
call an identity we create a persona to
use the young in term we create a false
self that we will present to the world
in other words we're so afraid deep down
on an unconscious level that we will
armored up with something some way of
presenting ourselves to the world that
doesn't let the world see the truth of
who we are that keeps us from living a
risking living our truth so will hunting
works as a custodian even though he's
smarter than all the all the professors
at MIT and in gravity she becomes a
person who is weightless she gets this
job in outer space because it's as far
literally as she can get from back earth
where so to speak the gravity of all
that pain is just weighing her down too
much and these are the people we meet at
the at the beginning it's the key is to
figure out what is this identity for the
character because then if you go back to
those six stages in stage one of that of
the outer journey when we meet the
character on the outer journey level
it's introducing us to the life they
live it's creating empathy with that
character by getting us to sympathize
with them or feel it to or worry about
them or because they are a very kind
good-hearted person but on the inner
journey level we are getting a picture
of what this identity is this character
is living fully in her identity in other
words when you're creating the
screenplay one of the things you want to
do in introducing you're your hero at
the beginning is show how they are stuck
in some way if you think of the
beginning of both Good Will Hunting and
gravity those characters are really kind
of frozen in place they're not going
anywhere
life is unfulfilled they're doing things
they're moving around but it's not a
fulfilling existence so we meet Will
Hunting getting in fights and you know
getting drunk and so on and he would
claim his life was fine but to us
there's something missing here and then
something's going to happen an
opportunity will occur they'll move into
stage two to figure out how am I going
to deal with this new situation and they
formulate a goal that out of motivation
is the goal that's going to take us all
the way to the climax of the story but
on the inner journey level here's where
it gets fun and exciting but tricky and
bad for the character because the rule
is whatever their goal they can't
achieve that goal unless they're willing
to step out of that identity and drop
that facade drop that persona which is
the most terrifying thing they can
imagine so you're giving your character
a horrible choice you're saying to them
you can have what you want and you can
be fulfilled but you're going to be
terrified you're going to be scared to
death because you are going to drop the
armor you've been wearing for most of
your life or you can keep the armor on
you won't get what you want and you're
going to be stuck in an unfulfilled life
for the rest for the rest of time and
that tug-of-war between being safe but
unfulfilled and being terrified but but
achieving the goal and transforming that
tug war between those two things is the
inner conflict that's what your conflict
is that's what that term means for a
character and so for the rest of the
story the inner journey is going to be
their gradual transformation from living
in their identity to what I call living
in their essence living their truth and
finding that necessary courage while on
the outer journey level it's them
getting closer and closer and facing
greater and greater obstacles as they
move toward the climax to achieve that
goal
you